hello
and das vidanya to all you russian
agents and ukrainian double agents
this is the reuben report direct message
for october
is it the 28th it's the 28th already man
i had to actually look down because time
has flitted away it seems like yesterday
was two months ago two months ago was
eight years ago
it is october 28th 2020 we are six days
away from the big election and actually
right after this
i'm going to vote i'm going to actually
vote in person and then don't worry guys
i'm going to mail in several other
ballots when i get home after that so
obviously i'm going to take part in
democracy at the highest possible level
but i am going to
actually vote in person when i wrap this
up
i thought in honor of election day i
haven't worn a jacket on these direct
messages in a while i thought i'd
go old school i'm wearing a jacket i'm
actually even wearing pants i usually
wear shorts when i'm doing this
not to blur the illusion for you fine
people
so it's going to be a big day around
here we've got a lot to get to
there are just all sorts of crazy things
happening we'll do some silly stuff some
serious stuff and the rest of it
uh before i get to that real quick
though guys uh the blaze media is
offering 30 bucks off an annual
subscription making blaze tv available
for the incredibly low price of only 575
a month as you guys know the blaze does
distribute the reuben report and the
direct messages i love working with the
guys
they're not my bosses glenn is not my
boss nobody there is my boss i make the
show i want to make we hand it to the
blaze
and if you want to subscribe you can get
it for a great price and that goes
through
election day november 3rd i assume
because the war starts the next day and
it would be hard to
track the people that subscribe at that
point okay we're gonna do uh
three stories for you today uh as
we speak right this very moment
jack from twitter and mark from facebook
and the google guy they're uh talking to
ted cruz and the other senators and the
congressmen
about big tech it's more of the big tech
theater
and unfortunately at this point six days
before the election it pretty much
is just theater because obviously
whatever interference they're running
whatever censorship
they've done whatever stories they've
de-boosted whatever
stories they've amplified the the
effects of those things have already
affected us in ways that we can't even
imagine and the idea that the government
is now going to do something about it
six days before an election is is sort
of theater uh but at the same time i
think
having them testify getting the
information out having more people wake
up
is still good whether the government can
actually do anything in six days i think
the ship has sailed on that one
so we're going to talk about that and
there's there's really an incredible
exchange
uh with ted cruz who as you guys know
he's been on the forefront of the fight
against big tech
and uh jack dorsey from twitter may have
gotten himself into some serious hot
water as per some information we're
getting
just in the last couple of minutes and
we're going to show you a tweet but it
seems
at least appears that he did lie under
oath and that
is a felony so jack could be in some
trouble and he could be in some trouble
because of that beard i mean have you
seen that thing
something something ain't right although
i tweeted out this morning uh and from
what i understand if you microdos a very
small amount of magic mushrooms
psilocybin
and you stare at his beard long enough
you can actually see
uh the algorithm the twitter algorithm
and how they band people you have to
stare at it for about five minutes while
my producing
so we'll talk about that uh we're also
going to talk
about tony bublinski which is definitely
the best name in politics right now it
keeps reminding me of soda popinski
from mike tyson's punch out way back
when remember you had glass joe you had
uh
king hippo and then soda popinski but
tony bubelinski who was a business
partner
with hunter biden and they had
involvement
with this chinese firm he talked to
tucker carlson last night we're going to
show you two minutes of it
and sort of unpack it although as i've
been saying to you guys the bigger
issue these days is not the specific
stories it's not even the corruption
it's that only people on the right are
talking about this only fox news is
covering it
and pretty much all of mainstream media
and lefty media is ignoring it and thus
we end up in two worlds and that that's
a big problem
uh so i'm going to play some of the clip
and then and then you'll decide
uh and then the third story for today
will be uh philadelphia is on fire right
now there were massive
protests and riots last night of course
you all know
protesting is fine looting stores
attacking people
uh ransacking stores these are not
allowed burning things down
not allowed not allowed so i'm going to
show you some video on that we'll talk
about it and of course this was in
in response to a police shooting and
you're not going to believe this but the
guy they shot
had a knife if you don't want to get
shot by the police don't don't pull a
knife at them
uh before we get to that guys i want to
talk about second thoughts
i'll even do it this way i'm going to
talk about second thoughts although if
you do it this way it would be a
different way of thinking about the game
second thoughts is this year's new
favorite party game that's sure to be
the hit
of your next friends and family game
night the play of the game calls for
each team to quickly create a list of
words for their opponents to decipher
leading to hilarious but puzzlement and
laughter
simply put it's a classic word guessing
game with a unique twist that allows
players to personalize the content with
their voluminous sense of word smithery
or just their witty and warped
imaginations each round of second
thoughts is a hilarious high-speed
attempt to stump the other team
both teams create a list of five things
using the letters revealed from the
colored dice
be witty and wise but don't take too
long because time is not on your side
the amount of time it takes your team to
create the list is the exact amount of
time your opponents get to guess them
second thoughts the quick thinking
versus fast talking party game fast
talking not bad
although i'm no ben shapiro get yours
today at second thoughtsthegame.com
that's second thoughtsthegame.com or at
your local target store
assuming it hasn't been burned down and
now back to today's headlines
all right here we go uh let's talk about
big tech so
i won't belabor a lot of this because
you guys know my my thoughts on big tech
i should say that look i am i am a
creature
of the internet i suppose right i my
success
and any reason that anyone knows about
anything i do
the fact that i was able to write a book
that people bought that people care
about what i think that my interviews
have
have had some relevance in some way in
the national conversation and everything
else the fact that when i
go to the supermarket people say nice
things to me these are all things
because of big tech these are things
because of youtube because of twitter
and facebook and the rest of it
so i'm very appreciative that these
things exist and i think
you know most of us especially at the
beginning remember remember
what big tech felt like to you maybe 15
years ago or 10 years ago
when you first got on facebook and it
was like oh there's an old
friend from high school i haven't seen
in 15 years
or oh i'm interested in this you know
gaming community and i never knew anyone
else was into this game or whatever it
might be that you could connect with all
of these people
you could see old family pictures all of
this stuff
and it felt kind of good and on twitter
you could follow
you could actually communicate with
celebrities that maybe you really liked
or an athlete that you loved
and there was all this good stuff and we
were sharing things
and then politics kind of gotten to
everything and then everyone started
fighting and hating each other and all
of those things and of course as i would
say to anything else it's on you
to decide how you want to behave with
these tools right big tech
technology in essence is like fire right
like fire is really
good and that it can heat your home and
it can make the water boil and that's
pretty good but it can also burn down
that house and it can
you know burn your face off so it's just
a tool and it's how you use it that's
the important thing
um so i'm not gonna sit here and talk
about these
uh hearings as if big tech is just so
evil it's not
in and of itself evil and by the way
these companies that are that
are created these giant behemoth
companies
you know they're just created by people
so when i can make fun of jack from
twitter or zuckerberg it's like
they're just people who have flaws and
and obviously have done some good things
too and everything else
um but maybe just people can't really
run these giant behemoth things and
that's that's an issue that we're all
going to have to deal with
and then of course there's all the
issues related to uh
to what happens what's the role of
government at that point
when when corporations have become so
big and powerful that the founders could
have never
possibly imagined they always feared the
power of government but now that there's
a there's another power that
you know in essence supersedes that
power so anyway
a couple of the big tech ceos are
testifying before the senate right now
it's happening right now so this is all
happening in the last hour or so
and there was an exchange between uh
senator ted cruz republican senator
obviously from texas and
twitter ceo jack dorsey
let's take a look let me ask you
something
you claimed it was because of a hacked
materials uh
policy i find that facially
uh highly dubious and clearly
employed in in a deeply partial way
did twitter block the distribution of
the new york times story a few weeks ago
that purported to be based on copies of
president trump's tax returns
we didn't find that a violation of our
terms of service and this policy
in particular because there's reporting
about the material it wasn't
distributing the material okay well
that's actually not true that they
posted what they purported to be
original source materials
and federal law federal statute makes it
a crime a federal felony
to distribute someone's tax returns
against their knowledge so that material
was based on something
that was distributed in violation of
federal law and yet twitter
gleefully allowed people to circulate
that
but when the article was critical of joe
biden
twitter engaged in rampant uh censorship
and silencing
and again we recognized errors in that
policy we we changed it within 24 hours
this is this is what you're still
watching the new york post you haven't
changed it
we have changed it they can log into
their account delete the original tweet
you forced the politico reporter to take
down his post about the new york post as
well is that
correct within that 24 hour period yes
but we
you know as the policy has changed
anyone can tweet something
you can censor the new york post you
expense or politico presumably you can
censor the new york times or any other
media
outlet mr dorsey who the hell
elected you and put you in charge of
what the media are allowed to report and
what the american people are allowed to
hear
and why do you persist in behaving as a
democratic super pac silencing
views to the contrary your political
beliefs let let's give
uh mr dorsey a few seconds to answer
that and
then we'll have to conclude this this
segment
well we're not doing that and this is
why i
opened um this hearing with calls for
more transparency we realize
we need to earn trust more we realize
that more accountability is needed to
show
our intentions and to show the outcomes
thank you so i
i hear the concerns and acknowledge them
but
we want to fix it with more transparency
so what ted cruz just did there was a
little bit of a mortal
combat finish him move he just uh
decapitated
mr jack ripped his spine out shook the
blood all around and then uh chucked it
over his shoulder
there's a lot to talk about there first
i just i should note that
you know ted cruz since he got the beard
and people have said this to me
something happens to people when they
get a beard
and they become sort of cleaner or
clearer or something
apparently because that that doesn't
seem like the cruise of four years ago
uh that guy that guy really knows what
he's doing and is making some seriously
good points i
don't know if it's fully beard related
but i think there's something there but
then the beard can also
overtake you as a human much like venom
and spider-man black suit spider-man and
that i think is what has happened
to uh jack with that ridiculous beard
he's been overtaken by the evil parasite
ted cruz me a couple other people if you
keep it trim like this
i think you can work with it instead of
having it completely own you
um so i want to quickly just uh
well let's start let's talk quickly
about what happened with uh with ted
cruz there
and then we'll we'll jump to something
else so ted cruz had a couple things
there first off at the end when he was
talking about
uh the the difference between the trump
tax returns
and this new york post story he said
that jack's response was oh it wasn't
distributing it it was reporting about
it meaning about the tax returns now
that's just nonsense because they were
distributing it
but the bigger issue right now and i'm
gonna pull up a tweet in just a second
is that ted cruz subsequently after this
interview this was just about an hour
and a half ago
he may have just caught jack in a lie
and you're not allowed to lie to the
senate that is a felony
because jack basically said that that
well first off
the new york post is still locked out of
their account that's number one i think
it's been about 11 12 days now
they are still locked out of their
account that's number one that wasn't
necessarily the lie the lie was the
implication that you could put this
tweet up and you'd still be okay with it
so let's throw it to ted cruz's tweet
which is just from within the last hour
and he said what jack told the senate
under oath
is false i just tried to tweet the new
york post story alleging biden
ccc ccp corruption still blocked
18 usc 1621 makes it a felony
to lie under oath to the senate in
essence and and jack is going to
obviously pretend he didn't know what he
was talking
about or mince words one way or another
but in essence he just lied under oath
and is going to be and probably should
be
in a lot of trouble you cannot post the
link then if you look in
in ted cruz's tweet he it was a retweet
of abigail marone
and she has a video of trying to do it
and ted cruz says he just tried to post
the link
himself so look this story ain't going
anywhere
as i said a lot of this is theater right
it's theater because it's
it's so close to the election it's like
what can you guys do at the time at this
point
however jack lying under oath does seem
like a bigger story
at this point and i think and this has
been the bigger problem with this thing
from the beginning
you you grow these companies so big that
in essence they have more power than the
government but you don't
have the founding documents like the
constitution that we have to keep
everyone honest to separate the powers
to have
checks and balances and then ultimately
what you get
is a guy like jack dorsey who i don't
know i'm guessing he's probably a
halfway decent human being
but in essence can't manage the company
and by the way he also is the ceo of
some other company
um i don't even remember what it is but
it's like oh is the job of the twitter
ceo so easy you can also be the ceo
of another company that that seems
pretty crazy and that actually brings me
it's a fine segue
uh to talk about talent inc guys with
today's high unemployment rates and
uncertain opportunities it's hard to
plan for the future
yet alone look for a new job here at the
reuben port we understand that the
struggle is real and actually we just
finished hiring a new position
and realize quickly how important it is
to have a resume that stands out among
the rest we got something like 1500
resumes when we just hired for my new
director
when it comes to writing your own resume
there's an unlimited number of things
that can go wrong and the cost of those
mistakes can be a missed opportunity
to secure secure your dream job getting
an expert opinion on your resume might
be the difference between getting the
job and getting rejected
as an employer i want to know what value
you bring to the table how have you
contributed to the companies you've
worked for
top resume is the world's premier resume
writing service
writing and analyzing more than four
million resumes and linkedin profiles
every year top resumes professional
writers will create a resume that
showcases
your talents achievements experience and
career goals using keywords
and skills that recruiters are seeking
job seekers using top resume are
interviewed two to three times more
often and have proven to be three times
more likely to secure a new job
than those using self-written resumes in
addition 68
of those who were hired within three
months of beginning their job
search with top resume you get a 60-day
interview guarantee
get two times more interviews or get
your resume rewritten
for free that's right for free top
resume also offers resume critique
service including a confidential
comprehensive review from trusted
experts
objective feedback on how well your
resume communicates your skills
and expertise and personalized
recommendations on how to make your
resume stronger
that's a lot go to topresume.com ruben
to get a free resume review that's top
resume dot com
slash ruben upload your resume today and
let their team of experts give you free
advice on how to make it stronger
special offer to reuben report listeners
and viewers top resumes offering 15
off professional resume writing services
that's topresume.com
ruben for a free review and 15 off
resume writing services
topresume.com reuben
and now back to me all right let's talk
about
tony bublinski which just it just seems
like the perfect name
for everything that's going on in the
world right now tony bublinski they're
going to look back
what was it like back in 2020 well we
had you know the guy with dementia and
the orange guy and everybody was going
crazy there were riots on the streets we
had pandemics nobody had a job
blah blah blah and then tony babalinsky
showed up and then and then
all hell really broke loose so look tony
babilinski is
a former business partner with hunter
biden
they were working with this chinese firm
he seems to know the family quite well
and apparently
tucker is going to release more audio of
some conversations tonight
but last night tucker interviewed tony
bublinski
uh we're going to play just a portion of
it and and then we'll decipher it a
little bit but again i bring everything
back
to this story only matters if you're
paying attention to it
and a lot of people just will not see it
and that's a big issue
but tucker really did a great job with
this last night and and you read tony
bublinski's words
listen to his words read his body
language does this guy seem like a fraud
and a liar
uh he's also a navy vet by the way and
remember colonel vinman he was a navy
vet and he didn't like trump so we had
to believe
him otherwise you're besmirching the
good name of the navy well now we're
ignoring this navy guy
so let's take a look at the clip good
evening and welcome to tucker carlson
tonight
we're going to devote the entire next
hour to a single interview something
we've never done before in this case
it's a conversation with a man called
tony babilinski
bobolinsky is the former business
partner of james and hunter biden of
course the brother and the son
of the current democratic candidate a
lot has been written about hunter and
james biden recently
but our story is not about them tonight
sleazy and shocking as some of those
details are
the story we're about to tell you is
instead about joe biden
the man who just days from now could be
elected president of the united states
joe biden and we can tell you this with
certainty had direct
personal involvement with his family's
business dealings in communist china and
likely in other countries as well
the former vice president of course has
vehemently denied that
he is lying tonight we can prove that
before we begin a word about tony
babilinski bob yalinski is not a
conventional whistleblower
he has no political agenda to the extent
he has supported candidates in the past
he's given exclusively to democrats
nor is he seeking money now from this
story this is not a shakedown of the
bidens or of anyone else
bob yalinski is already rich
significantly rich
he is a significant figure in american
finance and that's exactly
why the biden family sought him out in
the first place
they had no idea how to structure the
deals they hoped to cash in on
so they enlisted tony babilinski to do
it for them to do the math
now they're attacking him as an agent of
russian disinformation
and that's why bobilinsky is appearing
on this show
it is an effort to clear his family's
name of that slur
he had no choice the rest of the
national media have suppressed
his story reporters have ignored
intentionally ignored and in many cases
dishonestly distorted
scores of documents proving that bobby
linski's account is true
never in american history have more
power centers in this country
aligned to kill a legitimate news story
in the days before
an election okay so that was obviously
tucker's intro
last night and then the entire hour as
he said he's never done it before was
the interview with tony babilinski
you can find the interview either on the
fox website or you can see the the clips
all over all over twitter and everywhere
else but i wanted to play that actually
because
the the essence of it is right there
that this guy
is not in it for the money he's very
wealthy that's why the bidens brought
him in all that and we look
everyone can can whittle this down to
okay biden may be a corrupt politician
and everybody's corrupt and they all do
these things and hunter biden and
all the money he was getting from
barismo with no with no
expertise in in oil and energy and all
of these things like and i think partly
in a certain way
when people are locked at home and your
job and the country feels like it's like
in a very tenuous position that maybe
this story
doesn't get a certain amount of the
coverage that it would get in normal
times and and maybe
some of that at some level is actually
warranted because we have
problems that are like literally in our
home right now
um however the idea that that the media
is going to ignore this because it hurts
biden when we know i mean
really try to really try to think this
through
if this was reversed if it turned out
that donald trump jr
donald trump's son had business contacts
with a chinese firm and there were audio
tapes of saying you know
in essence you're going to bury us if
you release all of this
and donald trump jr had no expertise in
any of the things that he was getting
paid for and all of this
do you think the media would be running
with it yes or no i mean
the obvious answer is yes let's not
forget there was a week
about a year and a half ago where
everyone was freaking out because donald
trump jr had 15-minute lunch or meeting
on the upper east side with a russian
and of course it turned out to be
nothing
so again what we all want what are we
all what what thinking people want
is an honest decent non-partisan media
and we just don't have it anymore and in
many ways that
i think is sort of the driver behind a
lot of the trump campaign
for the people that don't necessarily
consider themselves traditional
conservatives
or for the people that have certain
reservations about trump
that's totally legit but people want the
mainstream media destroyed and it should
be destroyed this shouldn't be left to
tucker carlson having to do an
hour with this guy and then only
right-wing media push this
on twitter but that is what it's left
with and then and then what you'll get
actually is the complete reverse so the
new york times might write a story about
it
but they'll write a story about it how
it's part of the right wing
misinformation
network they'll never actually address
whether any of it's actually true
and we know that if the if the shoe was
on the other foot that they would
obviously be running with it if it could
take down
uh if it could take down donald trump so
anyway
do a little research on your own this is
one of those stories guys where
don't take my word for it don't take
tucker carlson's word for it don't even
take tony bobolinski's word for it
but watch some of the clips and i'm sure
over the next few days we'll probably
play a couple more of them
but i don't want to get lost in in the
total nitty-gritty of it
but it does sound like some pretty deep
corruption was going on and that the
very reason the very reason
that hunter biden and his uncle joe
biden's brother the reason that they
were
doing all of this was because they had
access to joe biden
and that could help their business that
is what government corruption
is i don't think most politicians are
above it
but that is what it is and perhaps that
colors
your feelings on whether you want to
vote for the guy or not
let's not forget this is a week after we
were watching the last debate last week
and biden was going on and on about how
trump wanted to build a golf course
somewhere i think it was actually in
china and he and it was
that he was trying to make contracts so
that he could get a road built to his
golf course there and it's like yes
that's why he became president
because he wanted to have a road built
to a golf course it's all
it's all just silliness but the
asymmetry between one side
is going to get pillared for something
and one side is going to get away with
it
that that is the bigger problem uh let's
jump over to the to the final story of
uh of the day today and then as i said
i'm going to vote
i'm going to vote in person and then
i'll mail in a couple extra ballots
because that's apparently what you do
these days um
the final story is that there were
massive massive riots
in philadelphia last night we actually
also had riots here in los angeles
downtown that was because
the uh the la dodgers won the world
series i forgot to watch baseball
starting about seven years ago
and then i just stopped watching but the
dodgers did win the world series uh
congrats to my new director connor he's
a big fan
uh first time since 88 i did watch that
world series tommy losordo or hershey's
remember that one
and then there were riots of course
downtown and you know you're not going
to believe this guys as they're booting
stores and
uh assaulting people and and you know
basically hijacking trucks and
grabbing whatever in the back and
handing it to people some of the
protesters were not wearing masks it's
like
you know come on people at least put the
mask on for the rioting i mean whatever
anyway that happened in los angeles that
wasn't directly related to social
justice
i suppose but in philadelphia
there was an incident where police
officers shot a man by the name of
walter wallace jr now he was holding a
knife
i'm not even going to get into it any
anything beyond that if you don't want
to be shot by police officers don't
don't bring a knife don't literally
bring a knife to a gunfight
um it will be up to the investigators
and the legal system to decide if they
overreacted and what happened and
everything else
but i'm just putting it out there that
the simple fact is and the way that the
media is covering this as usual
cops shoot black man and then you find
out in paragraph eight if you if you
bother going down that far and virtually
nobody does these days
that that he had a knife anyway this was
the perfect excuse
for black lives matter and antifa and
the rest of their cobra soldiers to get
out on the streets
and just cause absolute chaos and
destroy stores and attack people and
everything else let's just we had a
zillion clips
that we could have chosen from actually
um and several of them we had to
not use because uh there are often
people screaming things at cops
that are so defamatory that we know that
the way the youtube algorithm works if
if you do that you immediately get
demonetized and then push down in the
algorithm so we had to find
one that that wouldn't work here but
they're all over twitter you're not
going to see them on cnn obviously
uh take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yo yo
all right uh putting aside the narration
of that guy which sounds
sort of insane um those are cops running
away from the protesters they're
throwing things at them they're
attacking them
there's video of a car plowing into some
police officers
there are stores walmart was absolutely
decimated a sports store was attacked
[Music]
elijah schaefer who has a show on the
blaze he was reporting
from philadelphia he got assaulted by a
mob i mean they totally busted up his
lip and
he stayed out there and continued to
report
um and this is and apparently the the
philadelphia the national guard was
there but they stood down i mean there's
there's all sorts of weird things
happening
but philadelphia was basically on fire
it will be on fire again tonight
uh yes it's a democrat-run city yes two
days ago he said it was peaceful when it
started to not be peaceful
but nobody's going to stand up to this i
mean this is what if you live in a
democratic-run city the simple truth at
this point
whether you live in la or philly or
ferguson
or any of these cities they're all run
by democrats and the democrat
base is this it just is this those any
of those people that are actually voting
their bernie people their burn
it all down people as pete buddha judge
said to bernie
during the primaries you're for burning
it all down and and we're finding out in
essence
that is the truth the the anarchists the
marxists all of these people they they
don't want to win
in a in a conventional way because it in
in that regard
that that would be giving legitimacy to
the system but they want to delegitimize
the entire system
um look can you protest peacefully of
course you can
you should be out there you can march
you can use signs you should use your
voice these are the most american things
and by the way i never never see anyone
on the right
any conservative or anything like that
telling people that they can't protest
you're allowed to protest but what we
have started to allow
because we seemingly don't have any
adults in the room anymore but
particularly in democratic-run cities
what we've started to allow is you are
allowed to break into stores you are
allowed
to loot you are allowed to burn things
down you're allowed to take down
monuments you don't like
are people being arrested well actually
we know that in portland in seattle the
few people that were arrested
immediately get
released and then um spectacularly
talented
uh you know uh actors i think like um
mark ruffalo the hulk uh they they then
pay money and i think
leonardo dicaprio did it too and a few
other people you guys can correct me if
i'm wrong in the in the comment section
and i'm sure you will
uh but but then actors start paying for
the bail to get these guys out of prison
if you destroy property if you burn down
a store
if you attack people on the streets
you're a criminal
and if we are going to be a society of
laws which is the only way you can
organize a society you may not like all
the laws but it's the only way to do
this thing
then we need to start arresting people
but what also happens and this is what
the real danger is when you have these
clowns
like bill de blasio the mayor of new
york city who's constantly undermining
the police department the police hate de
blasio
that then causes all sorts of people
that are close to retirement they retire
then young recruits that should be in
the police department they don't even
want to
take those jobs because they know
they're not going to be defended
by the administration that they work for
this has happened before and it'll
happen again
new york city and my my great
grandparents and my grandparents
my grandma lived in new york city i grew
up in the suburbs but we used to we used
to go to new york city
in the in the days of david dinkins
before giuliani and it was a disaster i
remember i swear to you i remember
driving into the city once
and we'd get through the midtown tunnel
and we're right outside and they would
have all these homeless people and they
would come out and they'd
they'd have like dirty soapy water with
like a newspaper they'd be
wiping your window like that and i
remember this the um
it smelled like just the smell i
couldn't believe the smell of the city
and you know just
potholes everywhere and everything was
dirty and disgusting in times square
you'd never go to times square
well unless you would never go to times
square unless you were you were
into unless you were buying drugs
basically i was 12 i wasn't buying drugs
but i remember thinking i remember
saying to my parents like i would never
want to live here now
ultimately i ended up living in new york
city for most of my adult life and i
loved it and you're not going to believe
this
it's because of rudy giuliani it was
because a conservative came in after the
progressive
nut bag dinkins ruined the city and
businesses left and everything else and
then giuliani came in
cleaned it up got rid of drugs got rid
of homeless totally reimagined times
square i'm sure most of you have been to
times square
you may not like that it looks like
disneyland but it's clean and safe or at
least was
before the pandemic and then what
happens well then we had bloomberg and
he was sort of like half republican half
half democrat more democrat but
basically he was a he was a competent
manager
of the city uh and then and then what do
they do after that well then they bring
in
a progressive because then they decide
to ruin it again and what will happen
well they'll get they'll get somebody
like giuliani to clean it up eventually
but the question always
with progressives is how much
destruction can they sow before the
the mean conservative has to clean it up
so anyway there are tons of these videos
about philadelphia
uh i saw and again this goes to the
reality war thing that i keep pushing
with you guys
um jake tapper on cnn he is from
philadelphia he tweets about
philadelphia often
um out of his last like 20 tweets until
about 20 minutes ago since i
started this i can't comment on what
he's done since i've been live here
he had one tweet about the violence he
had a zillion other anti-trump tweets
and it's like you guys are exposing
yourselves constantly and again i don't
hate jake tapper
i think he's the last semi-decent person
at
cnn that's not saying much but i i think
there's something there but it's like
shouldn't you be
uh showing people about the violence in
the city that you grew up in
in the city that you know you purport to
love i think you probably should
uh anyway uh six days from the election
i'm gonna go
vote in person now then i'll mail out a
couple other uh
a couple other voter registration cards
or whatever it is
uh i'll be doing that today that's a
joke by the way i know media matters
now you see right wing leader of the
alt-right dave rubin announces he's
voting in person and will be mailing in
voter card ah we're media matters we
stink
um yes i'm only voting once you freaks
uh i will vote once i'm gonna do that
now uh
i think you guys know who i'm voting for
i'll do a more broad video about that
probably on friday we're gonna do shows
five days a week this
this week um but get out there keep
fighting for what you
what you believe in folks uh six days
again i'll say it every day till then
it's gonna get crazier and by the way
then after it gets crazier
it gets crazier too um but i'll i'll do
more on on who i voted for and
predictions and all that
uh throughout the rest of the week
thanks for watching everybody oh
and if you want to uh see some good news
we just posted an interview uh with
marion toopey
from human progress on our on our
youtube page and
on the podcast obviously and you can
hear that there are
awful lot of good trends happening in
the world
things related to the economy things
related to health
things related to the environment there
are actually good markers out there but
nobody shows them to you
so we thought that it would be an
interesting interview to put up this
week just like some good
trends that are out there because they
are out there so you can check that out
on youtube
thanks for watching everybody i'm off to
do my duty as an american citizen
goodbye